so what's cool at school how about  letting you decide which of many  projects you want to support and knowing  that the silver state has teachers backs  the nevada department of education  recently announced a collaboration with  the teacher funding website donors  choose to help them spend eight million  dollars in federal relief money on  pandemic related projects  whether it's helping high schoolers with  their mindfulness meditation  chipping in on computer stuff for an  elementary classroom or dozens of other  nevada projects the choice is yours and  we have a link to the donors choose  website it'll be in the online version  of this story on our website and if you  know something that's cool at school let  us know head to eightnewsnow.com look  for the community tab that's where  you'll find cool at school or just send  us an email cool at school at  8newsnow.com  you